we saw some nasty video in the teas a
moment ago
nobody wants roaches in their house but
apparently there's some kind of company
that's gonna
pay you now for roaches
yeah see if you guys would do this okay
this north carolina based company they
are looking for some homeowners to
welcome uh some new roommates the pest
informer says they will pay a whopping 2
000
to allow them to come into your home and
release 100 cockroaches inside what they
want to do is test a new pest control
technique in five to seven homes that
they promise is safe for pets the
experiment would last 30 days and they
guarantee the roaches will be gone at
the end john heather would you guys do
this for two thousand dollars oh
well let's be honest mercedes you can
speak to this as well we already work
with cockroaches in our building and we
don't get paid any extra for that so i
don't know if we want to live with any
roaches either my goodness
yeah there was one hour the other day
truer words have never been spoken
yeah i think we'll leave i like to have
my house roach free
that's nasty